[Music]
[Music]
this is another episode of hot boxing we
have a special guest here tonight man
whom Euston this is traitor to tell us
about two minutes from Houston born and
raised one named Houston - yeah I mean
when I first like you what 85 went to
Houston and so what's the McDonald's to
get some food I saw these girls come in
and a nice paid jeans on that cowboy
boot I know son of [ __ ] beautiful they
make the place a cowboy boot and whatnot
white people did that [ __ ] just not to
get back around to that but at first I
used to hate Whoopi be like man tix is
this country cowboy as a cowboy it
changed it don't huh but you can take
that and makes it sexy - good you're
never gonna get rid of the cowboy boots
yeah it's kind of flip them some kind of
way our culture y'all got horses out
here like in California some guys got
them up in there I'm up in the mountains
and stuff in the house smoke truth Oh
beautiful that's awesome you're not
offending you it I've been around my
whole life dude awesome man
so Trey day yeah the mayor of Houston
gave you this day yeah they named it
afraid a July 22nd tell us about it
there's gonna be here number 11 so what
happens on trade they probably four even
before I've got the holiday you know
they have been watching a lot of stuff I
do in the community
so they ended up giving me the day and
there was a day for the whole city to
honor me but I at the end of the day I
up here like I'm I'm cool man so I
switched it and made it a day for us to
honor the whole city you know so what I
do is it started just one day but night
and got so big you go to a whole weekend
stuff I go get the kids they school
supply school clothes used to be here
mean ization shots I started giving
mixed signals about people wanna
immunize their kids or not but that I'm
HIV testing ran out of a big park and I
bring all kind of jump plants and
different stuff in the Houston we don't
see snow so I actually make them come
create snow
I paid for that I bring camels kangaroos
a little bit a little bit everything and
then I go get all my homies whether they
at leats rap the singer's movie stars
and I bring them out there and the
reason I do that is because a lot of
these kids they only see them on YouTube
or TV but imagine and I didn't get out
there and go shake somebody like Mike
hand I'll take a picture of them that
they probably would have never had money
to get into the event with him all I'll
make it over now I present a tour face
to face so it just kind of give people
hope so I started doing that and then
they start just making that a whole just
charity weekend just pull everything and
there's five people in other states and
other cities so thing that's awesome now
so what do you want then we're talking
about you know your finances let's talk
about it what do you see in the future
of our youth well I see them going what
do you see that um the best of the best
road to which we should travel I think
man and it's crazy because I see it from
all different angles with me being from
the streets I understand that lifestyle
and then with me also being mature now
and growing I could see other outlets
you know like as opposed to what I would
have thought was cool back in the day
nowadays I probably pulled on me to the
side like nod I think to move I want
like ain't gonna watch you crash it so
but one thing I can't say about that you
even you know my
youngest is my little girl her name
truth she uh ten months they so advanced
you know saying they a lot lot sharper
technology makes them advance this phone
makes them advance it you know you don't
have to and when I was a kid this I'm
not even long not even kid I'm maturing
the eighties I'm I'm a grown man when I
want information I gotta go to a library
yeah we I mean they still have it now
but you know anything you know there's
no purpose or live it what purposes
unless you want some privacy alone in a
room yeah because they put the books on
the phone now - yeah yeah but um I think
man long is they got solid people and
they don't necessarily you have to be a
father couldn't I'm that that's the case
I'm a father to majority of the kids in
Houston it's just a matter of no one
they have somebody solid to guide them
and you know check them in there because
sometimes when you don't have
accountability you get too wild you know
saying because you you feel like man I
got an answer to nobody and sometimes
that could spiral into something real
bad so I try and get a hold as many as I
can I got the potential and show them
you know I'm saying they still can do
their own thing but just have somebody
to sharpen them up a little as I was
painting them in the room earlier say I
got a hundred million dollars I want to
give it to this community what do I do
I want to give to your community how do
you handle that for me what I do man and
it's crazy so not affect I'm I actually
your opinion so what's the first thing
you think if you see somebody helping
and they may show it on camera they may
record and they shouldn't camera yeah
what's the first thing you think because
it's - I'm people this is going on I see
now you think I think you know some
people do it justice so a lot of people
used to be at the point like oh I'll do
this and you're not supposed to show it
and some people if you know it's not
genuine and they doing like haha look
what I've done now you're not supposed
to but when you do sure how we show it
we go to one and inspire people into and
inform people because guess what a year
this almost two years since Harvey I
could take these cameras to certain
neighborhoods and
people who still haven't been helped
since that fluid hit like they walls
tour now
I remember rescuing lady toward the in
the last year her kid was sleeping in
the tent you know saying and you got to
think it's a fluid so on the outside of
the home it looked fine on the inside of
the home they got in the wall it's hard
for me to do and I remember I rescue and
it's two of us it's me and my partner
mr. Rogers so crazy
we don't do this ain't what we do I
don't do no saving people I don't be at
homes here DJ I rap but we just had the
heart for it and so I remember it was a
lady who was I believe she just turned
90 sleeping on a mole in the fistic
couch everything else in the house tulip
man we ended up taking up we ended up
putting on the a home a nice facility
rebuilt a home and brought it back you
know it's a lot of people that be
needing help still by far and so what
happens the other night when you get
money like that for you to say okay I
want to do this with us whatever people
give I like to let them to one come be
hands-on so you can see where your money
going to see what's going on but on side
of that they're not gonna do that rich
people I could move like that but see
that's the kind of people you know
that's where you gotta find the people
who genuine yeah they want to do it
because they want people to know but
that's good too because they wouldn't
want to get the ego look what I did for
these people that's could be getting the
money that's good if they want to do for
this you know it's crazy because I
didn't the fact that you think exactly
how I think about certain situations so
people used to be like well what about
if they doing it just for tensions wrong
in my mind yeah maybe maybe for morals
and principles but at the same time
people still getting the healthy may you
know I think one of the coldest thing
somebody told me in the process he's
like man no do I was out there on we
went in agree you know we would go to
apartment complex taking food clothes
water diapers everything dude like man
if you wouldn't Akane today the fact
that you coming up if I want to finally
he'll today for our literary is planning
on crashing myself i robbing the bank it
makes it was
now I'm that guy my family are those
guys my friends is that guy right there
so if then happen like the black of 1977
we had a blackout in New York City what
do you think'll you think we going to
people house no with Robin crashing
windows breaking in houses we're
breaking in stores that's just where
those guys that have nothing and never
gonna get anything they cut off a
welfare cut off our water cut off our
heat we're animals
yeah and in this light they don't it's
when you getting that your survival mode
so when you go on survival mode by any
means necessary you got to do whatever
you got to do to feeding before you feed
yourself to feed your family if you got
cute yeah it's a totally different
feeling everybody it's like chaos
anybody's calling for themselves it's a
lot more it's a lot more easier not in
it it was back then but it's there that
because you still got you got so many
different situations it may be a fella
who came home they can't go get a
apartment nowhere to stay can't go get
work and getting turned on every way you
may have somebody else who just lost
everything so it's like a lot of these
situations can spiral into some real
major so with what we do in Houston we
just give up people hope so guess what
we may not have touched everybody in
this room but the fact that I may have
touched him in him that may slow them
down from whatever they is thinking like
what if he got to know maybe it can
happen it can get to me too you know and
so that's how we keep it going to
Houston because it's a lot more it's a
lot more laid-back now actually that the
fluids and the disasters brought us
together more you can feel that way yeah
you're definitely you say that disasters
war they bring communities together you
know unfortunately yeah Trey take us
back man rapping music has been a big
part of your life obviously but you know
everything I've read up on you says that
you know helping people has been really
your souls passion throughout your life
I think there's just my heart just in
general man I think of course my music
is first and foremost and just what I do
but right it's still they'll change the
fact of my heart on me that's the the
for us I think of why people mess with
me music wise like I have a lot of
strong relationships just because I'm
genuine and then in the industry you
gets a lot of people who feel like
everybody needs some from you when
people come around me and they get the
they get that vibe and or like he could
with or without it so you don't need
like say it me and you if I say Mike man
let's go eat average person I'll think
like you let's go eat
I might gonna take care of it I'm gonna
say person we moving around in the
matter whoever with me if I'm it's my
little bigger than whatever it is
now you with me I got you know cuz I
feel like I'm a man at the end of the
day I can hold on so a lot of that still
kind of give people a breath of fresh
air we may think Mike to pay bill now I
think they should expect me to pay the
bill because I can yeah but then it you
got a it's like me I don't think if me
you went just me I wouldn't expect you
to because at the end of the day just
because you have it don't mean you have
to do it now if you choose to do it no I
can respect that have to do it you think
so yeah you know you gotta you explain
to me when you say so if I say man Mike
let's go let's go to the mall right now
the fact that you have it you think I
should be like me am I gonna get me this
yeah I me myself I can't speak for
everybody else me myself I'll never do
that well I probably I probably would go
without that would just be me alright
you know remember you said that
okay yeah we grew up together we always
had [ __ ] we never had [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
but whatever we shared now the
difference of what you just said is we
came up together I'm saying as opposed
to say if I'm somebody that didn't come
up with you but I just know you might
you know I'm saying I don't feel the
thing is if you do that Mike if you feel
that way then you got it you got to feel
like I gotta help every single person in
the world and there's nothing wrong with
helping there's help every single person
in the world but I think that's my duty
to help as many people as I can but
especially people that I don't know
yeah you're definitely if you came up
with somebody if we came up how
principally it would be right because
y'all struggle together but if it's
somebody you don't know you're not
necessary I came neighbors families from
around the neighborhood and everybody
else in the neighborhood that's my age
it's probably dead ask you're older so I
come around later I'm still got it on
some around maybe those guys that grew
up with didn't I remember the kids are
around mm-hmm
hey what's up let's go to the [ __ ]
mall boom but you know what that's the
right you got to think that's your form
of thinking and that would be right but
realistically for every other person
that got money they don't think like
that might they not have to be honest
with you Dane thinking parents they do
stuff they don't give a [ __ ] about
what's going on out there long as it
ain't affecting them and it's crazy
going back to Harvey a lot of people who
you would think Brian ain't we get to
that in a second I'm bad for radio
there's been 10 years worldwide so I'm
not able to make money so I'm nowhere
near as big as a lot of people but guess
what a lot of people never took one time
to come out give a type out buy a case
of water for somebody because at the end
of the day if it's not affecting them
directly they just don't give a damn now
your way of thinking
it's how I think you know I'm saying as
far as just wanting to help the people
but majority people don't think like
that
look at one of my 52 gonna be 53 in June
is in the June how long do I have
yeah what am I gonna do no really not
long I be gone soon you know you're fair
live natural dyes no [ __ ] shoot me
and some Sh I don't get my car I might
live for 14 more years it's over [ __ ]
I'm gonna do let's see again your
thought process of what you're saying
it's validated for you and it would be
validated for me for one that helped
people but again bro no matter what 90%
of the words don't want to do it my main
reason another reason - I help people
the way I do because my biggest fear is
some of what you just saying what if
something happened to me what about
Mikey so I'm hoping to inspire the next
you think people there
I used to think they [ __ ]
[ __ ] man's about me they don't
give a [ __ ] about me look what they did
I used to think that right but I
realized um
how the [ __ ] that I get where I got my
[ __ ] looked out for me
yeah and so you got support from people
you know me wait no [ __ ] looking out for
me you let me give me all this [ __ ] give
me a ego give me all this [ __ ] and I
supposed to keep it all to myself I
can't that's just inconceivable I don't
even listen I ain't no flying [ __ ] I'm
a regular Street [ __ ] but that's just
been conceivable that I got all this
money you don't got [ __ ] I can't fathom
that but you got a think my that's what
I do my money when I had my give it all
away
you have two [ __ ] my home oh I can't
believe that [ __ ] [ __ ] man me broke so
what would be your argument if you seen
we just said do the name Shawn that
we've seen Shawn Shawn just signed a
deal with baseball 80-some me but you
don't see Shawn helping nobody at the
end of the day you may feel some way but
you can't really do that about him
nobody doesn't know how to so I have to
show him how to he wants to help
somebody everybody wants to help
somebody no matter how they do even that
stingy mother is somebody they want to
help but they have to know how to help
people and maybe forgiving hoping that
one person that they love they could
learn to help more people you know see
that's there yeah okay everybody wants
to give somebody shake if it feels so
good as a dick thing once you start
doing it you can't stop it people I hate
you your family a cat what the [ __ ] are
you doing there quit the job you can't
be helped
get away I'll leave you Mike do you feel
like at this stage in your life you
should you feel like giving someone
money is the most helpful thing you can
do no but it's all that I know to do I'm
not gonna being I'm not gonna spend time
with them I can't do that have time for
I need my be my family I denied them
enough I need to spend time with them
and get to know them I can't spend time
with them all I could do is give them
money that's the most expensive most
wealthiest thing I have the only thing I
really have is my time
I can't give that nobody it's my family
that's an interesting perspective I get
I think I give both yeah I mean you know
I listen and understand I guess I never
and a lot of people used to always tell
they would tell me and mr. Rogers they
would be like y'all not taking no time
off for your sales or your family but I
think my key is understood you know it
kind of it kind of made them proud for
me to be out as much as I was but I
definitely know a year strong they
didn't really get to see me the way they
spoke that's right my [ __ ] when I'm 21
22 what I had kids are 22 [ __ ] you I
ain't giving all this up to you
[ __ ]
you can die started a fight I didn't
know this [ __ ] [ __ ] you I ain't giving
this up I come from nothing [ __ ] those
kids and then I'm this time when I mean
my kids start having not good
relationship so I said [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and I stopped everything they start
spending time with and this [ __ ] is hard
you know it's hard
what's your youngest my youngest is what
eight this is what 31 for man three boys
1869 and then my first little girl 10
months and she's awesome
you give me nothing violence
look at these people look at the neck
too old to be looking at my guns no what
is this how should I handle this and I
mean I don't know house I talk to my
wife it's just something that I handle
where's your wife sir she said she's
young and she's a young girl it's just
life you have to live life just like you
didn't learn for life you know life is
the teacher life is the true teacher and
that's gonna be the hard part for me
probably just thinking the Highwoods you
still chasing that the girls know that
too you know I mean that's how it is and
they look old saying the sins of the
father
don't be on the child and I have some
like upper-class kidding with the great
colleges and stuff and so I think of my
kids a sturdy Nia how do they race they
do white people and this and I look at
this weird and I say to myself I say to
myself my daughters do this because I'm
and then set a good example at home how
can I marry this [ __ ] [ __ ] look I
hate REITs my mother
that's not he talk so loud he is listen
I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] you all the
time I said [ __ ] up [ __ ] up well you
know man
our kids have their own higher power in
their own path as well so you know
they're gonna they have to deal with
those things just as we had to deal with
our demons on the way yeah you know Trey
I think I mean do you ever bring your
kids with you on the community service
stuff you do yeah with my kids I bring
them in in every aspect you know it's
awesome from from that aspect to even
just a street side because I feel like I
want them to have that knowledge of that
side to him before I let another [ __ ]
come around and show them wrong they
gonna learn everything for me so the
next person came amazed then with hey
let's go get in this car and go do it
like they didn't experienced everything
with me on Showtime a just this dis that
so I expose my kids to a lot never had
I've never what my kids you know like
our relationship is like homie so I felt
the way I did
it's a nutter whether whenever they
thinking or whatever they got going on
they gonna come holla at me so you know
saying that they helped me out a lot to
like I say my the first person I
probably not the whoop dance and my
little girl I'm just I feel it in here
holds them but as far as boys I just
keep a solid winner man because I feel
like transparency you know it sometimes
a lot of people feel that's bad to be
transparent with your key about this
fear like no just keep a solid with them
because you have to do think about every
girl I used to coming up the girls who
would be the finest and the ones that we
run run about the most be whoever
parents with the most treat didn't be
the ones we try to sneak today windows
door where we
I feel like I Mike he isn't never have
to do that like like not just let me
know what's going on you guys always
have to school I've always not take the
bus home I walked on the girlfriend's I
know father and mother was in the home
cooking five o'clock number you got
school at 2:30 3 o'clock yeah you got to
be honest with your kids because they're
gonna find out anyway yeah you know and
I think that's the most important thing
like you were saying that's that's a
blessing I have a seven-year-old
daughter and the fact that she can come
to me when she has a problem or needs to
tell me something I feel like that's the
biggest blessing I could ask for
as a parent I mean my keys my power any
more than anything man so that's I could
sit there rather than try to be in these
[ __ ] clothes and do all that so
I could sit back and just see the laughs
at my kids and [ __ ] with them and I'll
be I'll be cool clubs get [ __ ] old -
now I'm finding that my kids love with
my kids love the club my son know what
he doesn't know listen this is what he
did I can't man
he give money and I think what is a
table every night they gonna pay with
him and his boys and people they sit at
their table at the respect them and
treat them like a donkey that their
tables you don't you got a lead
it's crazy that's what it is that's the
best image you know you gotta whoever
get the most bottle since initiation you
know you got it
once you see the sparkling lights that's
all the attention on you it's all that
[ __ ] you know it's just [ __ ]
that people used to think that that's
that's what life is all about
no and weird way that is what life is
about like we look at it or your family
loves to look at you look at it rule
your family right you see the royal
family they have the establishment they
have their court gestures they have
their arm now there's what we call
executives they have their gods and
everything that's just like them to have
their table one guy's the king we have
this broad there have all his cronies
there have his people blocking his
tables like his king of nights and stuff
and that's the mentality we live you
know me though either high order and all
kind of it in every time
and everything little crews even little
third-graders there's always the packing
of hierarchy yet they picked though they
picked the leader some people think the
leader comes out and should I'm tough a
note the kids pick the leader they know
who the leader is
just like we know the leader is and we
pick our leaders you don't have to show
hey I want to be leader we pick him Mike
you just blew my mind brother as usual
nobody actually sweating oh you're right
you're totally right I mean that's this
is what I found out too
the leader is not always the baddest
[ __ ] you know that's the way
that the bigger the stuff him that's not
the leader the leader I had a brain I
can go to but he also had a brain that
guy he controls that guy yeah you know I
mean that's the leader leave the fights
without even fighting people fight for
him
my what you got man look at this [ __ ] -
this is what our new sponsor manscaped
[ __ ] sent us buddy
what the hell man in the old days a
mobile business dude this is a brand-new
exclusive ball trimmer okay they come
out that way this is the lawnmower 2.0
it's got an adjustable guide come it's a
snap in blade I mean I'm sure you could
use this on your beard oh yeah yeah
you're bald
it's got a non-slip molded assembly for
easy handling so when you're shaving
your junk you're not [ __ ] it's not
flying all over the place it's
unbelievable we this you get your very
own manscape tool kit look at this buddy
that's what one looks like huh ooh
it's quiet stroke now you don't have to
use the same trimmer on your face as you
do on your balls it's the tool for your
family jewels any fact that it comes
with a crop mop which is a ball white so
you got active pH controlled masking
[ __ ] manscaped and right now get 20%
off and free shipping with the code
hotboxing at man skate calm I just have
to say that I don't I don't think nobody
should be nobody should die in and death
row absolutely laws are not perfected
enough to do that to someone no you know
looking on the internet and you know
they say it's still some states that the
death penalty is a fire right on you
talk they do it in Utah they kill Gary
Gilmore like that the serial killer that
they put him in he killed my people mean
he paid they get killed they sit you up
[Music]
they just see the story about the lady
who got shot recently which one
five-time five-time about a cop no
swords in Baytown and I went to stand
for so what happened is she had a mental
illness but you know how of course you
know coming up in the hood you know you
can always have somebody in the
neighborhood they just they may be crazy
but everybody normal normal you know
like oh let's just emanating
so she had a mental illness her and the
officers staying they stay in the same
apartments so he even took her to jail a
few times you know her real well
this particular day she was walking
around picking up trash and he quote on
quote says she had a warrant so with
that he went to her ass and then she
trying to get home to where he's
slinging her around
I believe he tried to tase her so he
just he slang and I just had on the rear
roof so in the midst of the last
altercation as far as what he was doing
she failed and he said she reached for a
taser of the Taser that was I mean the
Taser that was already deployed if I am
mistaken shot a lot of times first shot
right between eyes and my thing is like
you know everybody knows she don't mean
home and even if it was a warned you off
duty and then if somebody's mentally ill
you have to call for backup
I'm looking at that video i'ma show you
and we get out here looking at that
video it looked like he was waiting for
that moment no let me explain this to
you from my experience right there's
just some people I used to feel this way
to this wired no there's just some
people that believe some people not
worth living their waste of [ __ ] space
on this planet he doesn't deserve to be
here
the worst he's a he's a waste of a
[ __ ] human being she's a waste of a
human pain there's people that feel like
that tons of people that feel like that
how do you even believe that if
[ __ ] means I didn't deserve justice
despite seeing this [ __ ]
makes me sick that's a [ __ ] the way to
be oh please that's just how the world
I mean creates people you know say
somebody shot my mother say yeah my
mother's away for life because of a drug
sting or she killed my father you know
people think that [ __ ] the world
how do we get those people to be like
you guys who are like let's help the
world hey how do we make that change
it sounds gonna happen overnight
definitely no I think the start you have
to do they have to be able to relate to
you because the day and nobody gonna
become I think the reason why the
community will [ __ ] with me the way they
do it because they trust me they have to
you have to be able to relate because
they if I'm going through something
you've never been through what I've been
through why would I listen to you so I
think the start is definitely glad to be
somebody that they respect to somebody
who's been through what they've been
through and they feel a lot of times
people have been through what they've
been through everybody when they down
they think only they did they're dealt
with doesn't no one did this before
mmm you know they think the only one
ever felt pain you know this is only
happening them and God doesn't like them
yeah you know this is just a test we all
go through testing life and sometimes
it's tested so hard we kill ourselves
it's just too much I can't take it
haven't a lot friends of mine you can't
take it to him money had everything was
doing it's just too what I can't take it
somebody no I'm gay I'm sorry please I'm
gonna kill myself bone and and and this
certain it's only a select a few that
weather the storm so I was checking out
early on bad for radio so what happens
if me being bad for radio I'm damn we're
a wide band from radio worldwide yeah so
what happens is say if you come into
town if you align yourself with me
obviously [ __ ] did you say so what
happened is the second trade a young
dudes out there getting ready to fight
one of them ends up pulling the gun out
and some gunshots go off this after the
event over but you know they they go to
it's always your type people like just
bash in the lower class and my whole
thing was we wouldn't know but so so
when it happened I get the car I'm
thinking damn in the news and I have a
fear they with this but the news and up
like everything trade did was right you
know we can't control we're going but
then it's the the the one that you would
think support the the black radio like
they the ones who went to bashing me so
they bashing me all across the radio I
finally get to call and speak my piece
so as I'm doing it we are again you know
and they it's your type people as they
always caused these problems
loud music this and then it's like one
who the [ __ ] is those type people you
know I'm saying like yeah I don't even
understand what that is so we argue and
they thinking this cute one of the
morning show hosts just know a lot only
thing I did ever in the whole situation
Carlisle fat ass and how that was just
in the midst that was in the midst of
doing what she was doing in the midst of
meat filling house feeling and I spoke
on it so what happens is you're looking
at a young black man that you got your
own holiday it's really damn they can do
no wrong in the city from they don't
matter if it's the mayor anybody come in
town this who they gravitating to so
it's like he's a tad bit too powerful
you know I'm saying like I remember
being told they was gonna make an
example out of me and they were trying
to make sure they removed my leg so it's
not not physically but nothing else I
can do so what they would start doing
was any artists coming in town hey if
you're lying yourself wouldn't we're not
gonna play your music any company that
that's entire hey if you want to
advertise with us you can but if you
deal with him when you can't advertise
with us
yes [ __ ] has a fat ass yeah that was
not good and I wouldn't saying she had a
fat ass
oh she was yeah so they started doing
that so I remember man it was so many
situations it would be like I used to
wind up cost I used to come to you snows
rear beard I don't know if it's theory a
big I hear I would be one of the main
hair line as most of the fact they were
always have to have somebody from the
town oh no I remember being called by
didn't one day like hey man you know we
apologize we're not gonna be able to pay
you we not we can't allow you to touch
the stage because
we do that they won't promote our event
so it just got to a point well company's
not dealing with me that the artists not
able to do because you you ain't gonna
get played
- I remember Haiti happened Barbie was
doing some stuff with Haiti where they
ended up needing food water so when it
comes time to get the people that people
reach out to me because they know we'd
get the people out there so he reached
out to me we get ready to raise the food
and the water and stuff to send over
them they tell him hey you know I know
he want to help these people but we're
not gonna help you push this if he owned
that you got to take him up you know I'm
saying so they put people in
uncomfortable situation where it's like
do I stand there [ __ ] with tray
a staffer was right I thought [ __ ] off
my money so at first I used to be I used
to be mad at the world but then I got to
a point where like I get it you got to
take care of your family cool imma
figured out the first couple years
brought I went from being on top to
losing everything I say everything
losing friends family everything I lost
everybody yeah but I gotta be I gotta
keep it I had a lot of friends come
visit me but as far as doing business or
I lost everybody who I wanted to be with
who I wanted to be my friends and stuff
people I really wanted to be friends
with that could make a life of me over
and to start a whole new life me whole
new new people beside the people that I
had you know I think that just built
that build stronger character for us
because if you look back in the old days
or the power of days you see people
losing and start knowing you have to you
know it's in some people's DNA is to win
you know even not even for the right
reading it's because I want to show them
and that's not the right reason but it's
just that I want to be somebody I don't
want to be nobody I've been nobody all
my life I'm gonna have opportunity to be
somebody so it's been it's been going on
11 years Nestle and I'm still trade ya
right relationship with your hometown
you could do so much on trade a trainer
is just this is the moment to use as a
marketing traded market
you know you could tell people who you
are and what you are what you want to be
whenever you want cuz you're a day you
say who you are and that you can't look
that I know used to be that way used to
beats me down cuz I wanted to make money
I wanna do commercials that I had a
taste of it before I did PepsiCo the
commercial setting I did Co that
commercial I got that [ __ ] I got paid
with Jordan and with getting and when I
got [ __ ] up I wanted to that you know
but I guess just such a yeah I got
caught up in such a bad nasty talk world
I never was able to get that back you
know I was really labeled bad [ __ ]
scary bad [ __ ] don't [ __ ] with him he
may not show up and when he do show me
my smash it was time for being late it's
just I was just talk you know a little
feeling I think I know I know I know I
[ __ ] up cuz I know I wanted that you
know we can't live on it now I learned
something you know definitely that was
the sake of now you where you are yeah
it's real like I had no control over the
situation I only have control over me
make sure my side of the street is clean
I have no control of my wife she had to
take care of her side of the street it's
enough to make sure mine is clean
because mines is not clean everything
[ __ ] up you know fuzz is dirty and my
kids are dirty we're still gonna strike
our strive and we're gonna still do well
but if I'm [ __ ] up everything is gonna
die
same with street rules
yeah when you remove the head everything
kind of fall everything so tray what do
you got lined up for this tray day I see
give them hope like no other man and I
remember coming up before I even made a
rap and thank the god I'm good at
knackles back then I suck when I first
started cuz I got a I started rapping I
got a brother he's doing two life
sentences right now and you know coming
up in a hoodie to look up to your father
older brother big homies and my older
brother was my wear name dinky that's I
started rapping but I remember coming up
I would be wanting to go to shows I be
wanting to
meet famous people I even get helped by
people and I didn't had opportunity I
always say man if I ever got on I want
to totally opposite of that and be
accessible to the people and I've been
doing that ever since you know that's
really important people I'm 50 I'm their
our youth they got to be able to touch
you to know that you're real yeah that's
it makes a major difference listen I met
Muhammad Ali when I was like what 12
years old 11 years old in a reform
school he came to visit the kids and it
[ __ ] me up I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened to me that day life changes you
already fight man you was C so [ __ ] like
that no no no I didn't know a box of
what Isis great guy holiday buddy look
[ __ ] quit what the [ __ ] is he no idea
that's a great story and they loot it
you could just see his energy you'd feel
his energy you were just like that's why
was he was cool a back Oh
often funny happy talking to you it's
loving gets warm powerful crazy [ __ ]
trade a providing a lot of great
resources to the community no more music
yeah yeah definitely music it it's so
[ __ ] up life be taking this toll on me
so every once in a while I finally get a
break like and jump back into the music
but I'll be dealing with four trying to
help people save people from dealing
with life the keys just taking care of
the city but definitely the music the
crazy thing I got over 2000 over these
records like I I can't go like it me you
said 101 I can't be like man Mike I'm
just going through it right now it's
hard what I do is I get in there and
I've been on a microphone that's why I
got so many songs but um right now I'm
gonna finally get ready to put out in
the first record I'm gonna put out comes
out on the 14th it's called nipsey
you know me and if she was really real
close and what I'm gonna do is when I
put out the song in the video
everything from the downloads to
purchase and it just
dream and go to the trust fund for the
kids that they set up so that's gonna be
the kickoff and then once I do that I'm
pretty sure I get back to it and then
again look right when I do that trade
coming up so I get occupied doing so
much other stuff man so it's definitely
coming my new album Kyle exhale like I
feel like man this is the time I'll
going through so much stuff I gotta just
let it all out
good tell me I'm you know exactly some
questions why you want to save the world
well why do you feel you can oh I don't
imma say this I don't think I could say
it aware but I definitely feel I'm gonna
save as many as I can to definitely make
an impact and I just feel this need you
know I'm sentimental
the worst feeling and you should know
that the worst feeling on earth is
feeling you ain't got nobody just you
against the world you on your own that
can lead to any type of destruction
interesting because now my feeling now I
didn't help anybody that's why I think
now I didn't help nobody I didn't help
enough people I kept too much money I
spend too much on myself you know so
crazy I feel a bad spending money on
myself like that bro I didn't understand
what taking my young I didn't understand
what's taking care of yourself I thought
taking care yourself was [ __ ] a
hundred girls getting drunk getting hot
by myself night drive myself a nice car
by myself a nice house or a plane I
thought that was taking care of myself
being good to myself that was killing
myself you know I mean I was dying to
live you only live it feels good it's a
drug listen once you start giving people
shitty it's [ __ ] [ __ ] it's always a rat
oh you get that respond whatever it is
if she hugs you you think she want to
give you the book that somebody cries oh
thank you Oh [ __ ] it's over I get done
you [ __ ] done yeah you write that the
crazy thing with Eva without people help
us - you never know you never know but I
just continue to do what I can like you
know like you what I just did I believe
a week ago so I
found out in school in high school they
have student fees so if you don't pay
for your cap and gown and all that you I
believe is he do you allowed to walk the
stage and you don't get your diploma or
you get your diploma you can't walk the
stage so what I did anybody wants to
walk the stage yeah so what I ended up
doing is I went to some schools and I
just covered they bill I went and got
him all that but what the part I'm
getting to is someone as I did that you
guys believe every school in the city of
Houston was yeah I ain't got it to do
every single person in the city but
somebody just did that
all right it was a Howard some school
somebody somebody got my graduate yeah
whatever just graduate all these names
on graduate and get their [ __ ] them
know the college did your movie their
college did that you hear that was
amazing it was Larry how do you deal
with that because you can only give so
much how do you deal with the people
that I mean I do my best I try and talk
to him a little look like I'm I'm at a
point while I'm tapped out and then I
try and find other things to do like for
instance um I remember Christmas we took
families on this last year we took
families on $20,000 shopping spree
families that that's going through it
because a lot of them have to they have
to show you know give it to get a store
how many kids they got or some of them
don't have cause some of them they got a
place stay so we pick the ones they need
the most and we would take them and do
different stuff like that and sometimes
it turned out even good I remember
JCPenney partnered with me well hang on
this is say partner but we gave them
75,000 and we took 200 families and they
gave me not only with me giving them
that money and we picked the 200
families they let us get stuff and
almost like 50 or 60 percent off so you
imagine
families walking out of there with trash
bags yeah but no one should be done you
should work with all the corporations
for whatever the corporation together
the Society is all of them all
should be help helping out the
distribute to the people with less
fortunate than themselves I like I don't
get help for trading I don't know how to
get a spot not saying I'm sorry they
traded today yesterday all this stuff
happened they gotta be sponsoring
trainers will say I gotta figure out the
trader I gotta figure out how to get to
know this is how you do it you get your
lawyer you call them and explained and
you go with them of course so they can
see you and your course you bring some
of your articles children shouldn't some
of your um put your tape and show them
some uh television reviews about trading
and how people so happy how to me it
gave you trading and boom the Mayor was
there oh really
so I can meet the mayor with you all
right let's fight this um finance this
guy once political powers involved all
these guys want to meet the mayor the
mayor's go tell everybody this is a
great philanthropist to these guys the
own JCPenney and Woolworths and all
these guys in the National Bank you have
to get them or less all that's when um
the government and big business works
together but the thing is how do you get
in the door because I trade a still
haven't got means it's no no no this is
how the junior low you're going you make
these people aware of trading and how
the people come in they sponsor and when
they see all these people sponsoring
your trade how many people come out to
trader you a thing
yeah need to send out that's eight to
ten thousand customers they see I need
to put a picture up here JCPenney so
they could see that why they [ __ ] I'm
worshiping this [ __ ] alright they gonna
see that - this is associating with him
they love him they love this yeah but do
you think can carry take it what you can
do dick that's what you can do you can
draw that's their customers I want your
customers I want your fans I want your
fans to donate to just distribute to my
company I want their twenty dollars
fifteen bucks whatever is twelve million
I want I want ten thousand twelve ninety
nine
how much you think that is the ad that
Trey who would be your ideal sponsorship
well this year man I can honestly say
what I'm doing well faster in Kodak
anything from weed people can be against
money
anybody know any water company parent
company yeah yeah I think you know I
think any just big big business without
what I did now is that you heard of
stock ex no no stock Exodus they read
they they're famous for shoes people in
his shoe hairs go to them so what they
did was again cuz like Michael saying
well I feel if people got money they
suspend it I still don't want to ask
nobody so what I do is oh you got pride
huh you know what keep it real with you
think I do to experience your glow but
now wait so what happened is now I reach
out to some of my homies and I'll be
like like for instance um Callie the PGA
sucking them what they do is they give
me a pair of shoes that they mail wore
in the game or something that people
can't really get and stock XO I'll put
it up and we made like last year we did
15 pair of shoes and we made it to where
you don't matter if you eight years old
are you 48 all you have to do is put
five dollars in the pot and you get your
ticket you can give them any tickets as
you want and they get rifled up at the
end that's not a rich to graze Mike if
the guy they do it they do it online
alright yeah sort of athletes their due
date and then the robbers did do they
videos and stuff here to be a whole
campaign and it's the site that they'll
go to they raffle online or whatever
money they get they kick back to trading
so like last year trader and to spend
like $130 no see that's not business
that's a bad business do you knock money
that's supposed to come apart that said
Finch this is trade everybody's supposed
to donate and tribute to you put the
troll Foods learning process I'll steal
again and I'll frickin I'm pretty sure I
get some game from you I gotta just yeah
and pride don't give imma keep aside I'm
Lionel Trane's fan I do have
but not prior to where I feel I'm better
people prior to I just you know in life
when you get disappointment so much you
just get to a point where like I'm gonna
prevent myself from being disappoint
listen this is what it is you don't want
to believe in kind of mine you don't
believe that they're your friend deep
down in your gutter core you don't
believe that they're your friend that's
why you don't you like to be my thing I
was doing love the husband whatever you
do it though but deep down side you know
it's a possibility I give you some
[ __ ] you do like cuz they feel you
going to this this you automatically is
jump on your back we're doing this
together well you have to ask them my
friends see me suffer in and see me
working hard they generate with me
they're not anything that's what we
doing that's all my friends do that's
something you want to want me dead you
know I mean that's like what they gonna
want out of this [ __ ] you know I mean
but that's just what friends do even
though they got bad habits maybe they're
not perfect but that's what a friend
does let's do it well you got to
remember them friends are scarce it
ain't that many of them so those like
that that the process man that the
process that's because you have to be a
friend once you are a friend they will
be your friend
trust me I know you say our [ __ ] Vince
you guys you think that too but people
are wanting somebody to be a friend we
all want to might be a friend but we
don't trust no [ __ ] [ __ ] these [ __ ]
ain't right out here you know we all
look for friends cuz most of our friends
and I know now becoming they become
lonely next thing you know we're hanging
other people we never hang out one
because we're lonely people who might
not be good for it because everybody's
dying everybody they're not there no
more so these guys are still around a
neighborhood we never [ __ ] with each
other before so now I'm [ __ ] with them
you know I don't feel good because no
one else is around I'm around my
neighborhood and they're around my
neighborhood so who else is in the
[ __ ] neighborhood after this guy had
to learn to be friends remember saying
I'm gonna kill this [ __ ] I'm all
on [ __ ] dog days we have to learn to
love each other and be friends we're
designed not to like each other from
hundreds and hundreds of years and even
when we were in Africa we design I hate
that tribe and put them in slavery to
these European [ __ ]
because that's how we've been designed
to compete against everybody
competition you know see me am I talked
about this is how we did even with white
people they are we all learn the
competing in theatres the betrayed to be
smarter than him for without thank him
and I'm smart him we weren't taught that
that's you know we're coming to another
aging where we even eat different now in
another 20 years we eat different we
won't eat meat people won't [ __ ] with
animals with sadistic people just like
killing it we won't even eat them no
more we different kind of [ __ ] I know
you can't feed on that with your
grandkids will know I like I used to be
290 I love thought my way up start he'd
build enough and it goes away once you
start working doing positive stuff that
beating that [ __ ] goes away I was 320 I
don't think I don't think we're meant to
eat animals I don't think people meant
to eat animals even though they make us
strong you know during the process they
kill us must be gorgeous if I was just
saying I was reading in the Roman Empire
people loved eating so much - a day -
they couldn't even one day they cause
it's work they - up and then they ate
again they couldn't help it
vomitorium and they used to take all the
gladiators blood for their aches and
their gouts and stuff rub it on a gals
didn't even drink it well Mike what do
you think about the like decadence of
ancient Rome and how that was really the
what led to their fault they're just
consumption and how they loved richness
and I got it from the Greek Roman didn't
know anything really you know most their
knowledge and stuff they received
basically from the Greeks and now to
build it took the Greeks cause and had
gave them different names they were kind
of barbaric the Greeks pretty much
educated them and he has took it - from
from from a Greek education and put it
in a Roman perspective was the city of
Rome Italy was that the center of Rome
I've been to Rome
and I don't know what part of this but
wrong I don't know what part of this
it's close to my line it's close um well
it's close to Sardinia but this is like
the southern part of it and stuff know a
few hours away but um it's just a big
old nasty fitting yeah was that the hub
of ancient Rome though now the hub of
the world was the hub of the world at
one yeah now do you think it's New York
City New York City yeah but Vegas is
building up a new city you know I mean
they're building up I'm LA building more
you know in cities a building running in
new cities you never know you might find
new property somewhere they still run
out I'm all watching that you took it I
mean YouTube nut they got people haven't
seen that's been in Ireland for 6,000
years for 60,000 years yeah nothing and
never seen a white man - this year in
India outside in this jar with people
but there's other there other tribes - I
don't know their name but the Jawas and
some other people they killed that one
guy - Kim and then wrap a rope on a neck
and drug him in the forest never heard
from him again yeah
and this is cool this is why I took as
I'm watching them the dancer if I have
opinion I'll always look up and I found
that these guys climb trees like monkeys
they kind of like 30-foot tree that way
on the top - people look so small so
you're walking looking from they're
watching you it's a trip you do that why
you never seen people the first thing
when I saw Steve you know Steve went on
there Steve oh yeah and they saw Steve
looking this way that they grabbed my
started biting on and chewing on him and
humping on their prey and smacking I'm
beating on his [ __ ] was like watch me
let's see that should only go out right
and Steve hate me I'm tired of you
[ __ ]
oh man it was crazy it's christiev is
out of his [ __ ] mind I would go mad
at this guy bit me team and sky never
been to the doctor in his life he'd
bitter
Oh maddening for over 60,000 years you
never been to a [ __ ] doctor my whole
generation up in the doctor and they
bite you get biting on you there means
does the product wrong you see
no it's weak we kill them we could with
some nasty [ __ ]
we totally be around them they die with
them that we are from nasty [ __ ]
and that's what they did to us Europeans
came over after Indians and african they
killed them with Jamal they killed them
more with diseases than they did with
the knife from the gun yeah how about
that dude we saw yesterday
or whatever dude that was the agori
Sanibel no listen that might have been
the same guy that was with Steve OH
Steve Hilary [ __ ] in the face
with and I think he took some [ __ ] and
[ __ ] I think he humped a nigga's ass and
did all this [ __ ] and I'm like oh [ __ ] I
said we should just mind my Mane Tyler
I'm a sick I'm dog my first idea to kill
them all and [ __ ] feed let's go back
there and I'm saying yes doc if they are
Mike you know it's crazy cuz that's why
no oh yeah because this is one
particular time it was the guy that saw
the tribes there yeah they believed they
were Golda so they went in a if utilize
them and that's the first thing I said I
wonder do they have gold that was first
yeah cuz all ancient people have go for
some reason it attracts no no that's my
first or they do they have any wealth
because they all have gold for so why do
they why why did that go they are not
all an indigenous people have a place of
mine ancient my where gold I don't know
where it is that they all have gold
trinkets
where did I get this [ __ ] phone they
have two chains and necklaces gold I
know where to find it and that's what
the guy he figured it was gold basically
wiped out around 20 of them he took him
he didn't really know yeah I think it
was India well now there was an island
outside of India of course there's a
jail Dorado the city of gold in the
second South America well last death
that might be fictitious death
this is history that's not the truth
found present tray you got to come to
the ranch Oh Jay I know you don't smoke
but this isn't beautiful you perform
yeah listen we had we had before we had
Miguel so ASAP ferg a few a lot of great
artists Mel and listen we're getting
ready to get um we're gonna have kind
first of all yeah
Drake we may get Drake and Meagles and I
Billy I Lee forgive me to talk to um
okay come in no matter which cake you no
matter who else come and just call me a
part of a headphone and a radio coming
I'm a senior out so yeah I get a sense
out this week yeah keep [ __ ] nah this is
gonna be top of line for you yeah it
make me think the mic what you saying
about what friends our family's supposed
to naturally do it they watching you you
go through it or watching you something
that you want if I can genuinely help
all my time out here we ought to know
all of us together we are chillin are we
smoking this [ __ ] you don't smoke did
you [ __ ] that your clothes are not
looking good you know possible we don't
know but we know you don't look the way
you don't have to tell you right you
know I got to tell you if you [ __ ] with
your friend I'll have to ask you think I
get some money if you need some [ __ ]
money it's common [ __ ] sense but you
sometimes you got to tell people cuz
they're not no one ever taught them that
if you don't ask them they don't know
these [ __ ] say this [ __ ] a closed
mouth don't get fed no [ __ ] [ __ ]
if you blind [ __ ] you don't get
fed that's what happened you need to see
if the [ __ ] [ __ ] up or not or
if he's not if he can't be helped yeah
this is what we doing man I want them to
seek a that rat I'm firm guys yeah right
here it goes her here look at my crowd I
had it for 4,000 7500 King
this dog
I had a miracle round and [ __ ]
look faith going looking Miguel doing
his [ __ ]
but know what I found out um the crowd
is nothing that into that arm be no more
they want that hardcore [ __ ] yeah yeah
love day I thought he should deserve but
they were crazy for this man right here
yeah we're the same Vegas with you nice
and Desert Hot Springs
he's like an hour hour away from here
before you get to Coachella
yeah Coachella let's go yeah yeah it's
right in there
oh it was dope oh it's in October
you took houki it up there okay then
come near who could then cut out man who
can ask down here oh yeah but it turned
out to be a blessing man cuz I reached
out to who kid as I was telling you my
bro um James the beast Wilson hey you
wanna is either solid like man who kid I
remember cuz I was at a party with Shaq
Shaq had me on fighting in Vegas who I
actually met you for the first time I'm
like man who we gotta find Mike I don't
give a damn how we find him I wherever
you to me and I as a brother I want to
make sure I make that happen so I can
introduce Timmy at home houki was like
well you know Mike got a podcast he was
talking to free and I was like for real
and I ain't no afraid in who I was so
when I was talking to him he's like what
ya feel like we yeah I know you do this
this and this and I was like if I manage
you like to be on the podcast I don't
like [ __ ] man oh that's a blessing
that's more of an honor hair [ __ ] yes
thank you know I'm here looking at your
life right I'm thinking right and I said
um it's never been a time in life when
people didn't have go I'm talking I even
came it's never been a time I'm like and
people don't have gold teeth yeah even
if they just saw the gold
it's knew how to put in the tv9 you
think maybe it was um that's interesting
they've been doing it Africa forever
you know in your mouth that's why they
say the price of gold never go down
that's they say diamonds everywhere she
goes
is where like I'll say diamonds they
were gods but listen this is what it all
comes down to right this comes down to
our this is human this is a Shaolin is
I'm know our goal is it doesn't cost me
much it's white gold no I would I go
more than others but it's prettier it's
more noticeable than white gold and
silver and everything so it's not that
it's workable noticeable it's prettier
than silver and white gold and platinum
and all that stuff you know I mean all
that stuff the platen all that stuff is
much minutes ago but it's coal has
always been in a warning for us you know
country's been conquered over gold and
bought over go port wit go they listen
we can't get enough gold it's too much
it's too much gold from human
consumption in this planet if every
people if every person over here to come
I don't know you think that if every
person of the plan took a ton of gold
still be enough in the planet the
planets made out of minerals all the
planet Jupiter Mars or less doesn't mean
other minerals astronauts amendment when
they crack booming and scientist looks
at it with his microscope you see the
diamond goes the particles or emeralds
everything coming out of the crash
that's why they keep honey well that's
why they want to go to other plants for
they could dig and get all the minerals
out of them the food the minerals too
many what do they use them for the
diamond the platinum is all that stuff
but only for decoration
no for gold they sell it they hold it
mmm fell on the market you know I mean
for greed the richest people who will
have the power since I might do another
plan to dig but what do they think that
contains but the planet no the minerals
submit it was a diamonds gold platinum
why I don't know I don't know why they
made it worth so much the people there
yeah I believe you can give some
electric out currents and from left off
to look electricity you have a lot to do
with that and currency and power I'd
love to do that
at that too hmm maybe they feel like
they're getting something from the power
of the frequency or something I don't
know
you know I know even one more important
than diamonds and gold and that's tough
there's a minimum in Africa that has to
be you have to have it in your cell
phones you don't have it won't work and
so they they buy thousands and thousands
of acres in Africa needs to digging
these miles to get these black minerals
for our cell phones oh no the [ __ ] it is
yeah you know exact gold is black stuff
sitting black we put in our cell phone
that's the new big thing that you know I
mean they keeping a secret from us some
of the stuff you everything can't be
believable you this is very mundane very
easy not complex at all you see them
[ __ ] digging for it they see them
showing you they're not hiding it you
gotta go look for it yeah I'm making
sure I'm heading back to Houston ax
after I leave here so I'm gonna make
sure I seen you on some of my waves here
for the bump box you probably have a
fear day especially where you say you
know how the old boom box is you see
they the new ones but of course you know
it's up today northern to from the phone
yeah it's different size is the big big
one you probably gonna be able to kick
it should be able yeah it's gonna tell
me why did you why did you get your
teeth lace I could take them out but
yeah I mean take mines out mines I had
to clipper man I don't know why I got to
pull them up my teeth will be knock put
the two teeth in there so when I happen
when I lost one arm when I think i'ma go
ahead come on the teeth there yeah I
just I don't know it's just part our
culture in Houston I had like my mother
had it so I don't know why she had it
from the south so I had it I put it in
my mouth
also your tire you tired to the South
there you Virginia okay yeah yes so it's
a part of coach I've had it since then
Nass like man I've had this alone
someday they give
just put it in some days I do I don't
know man this is for being in a game as
long as I have nothing like sometimes
like good money put on jury and then I
see the history I like I watch people I
watched on like African and they had
gold teeth in their nose eighty times I
didn't know really they didn't have
cameras but um you know during nineteen
tenses I saw pitches
you know 1902 1890 you see people go typ
bcgirl thetac arrogant and cigars
Wow and so I asked us it was like he's
born in 1908 my mentor I said why do
people wear gold teeth in there he said
it was a sign of wealth you got gold
keep your big shot and as you noticed
most of them minorities had gold because
they were insecure and he wanted people
to feel that they were somebody said he
had gold teeth
what's my gold teeth without a jury and
stuff you think and in 1989 five thirty
years out of slavery and every
millionaires and some people have been
made as gifts coming out of slavery
thirty forty years out of slavery
somebody's a millionaire you know I mean
fifty years our slavery a black woman's
a millionaire that's incredible that's
wild d'etre you want to let anybody know
anything in particular that you add
again touch with you how can they
support trade a first we gonna let them
know they go far less than Tyson rents
this you have to know how to manipulate
trading in your name you manipulate your
heart to your heart leaves you broke I
found that out too we can help people
and still keep our money and give them
more than we had when we were given the
money physically that's where I had to
find out definitely what they might
worry about everything so I'm definitely
gonna sit on the toilet figure it out
they're gonna kill you you know when you
put your when you put your effort your
everything on Sol all these people all
these people are really dependent on you
that's awesome it's awesome when they
depend on you
golly man that's of great feeling but
then you got to keep feeling yeah I keep
feeling feeding that fire you gotta feed
that beef and that's when you need your
supporters your sponsors to help you
feed that big that's just the right off
of them they're gonna get more back in
return that's there's nothing that's
nothing for them that's mine they're
allowed to give away in their country
it won't be tacked for so that's gonna
be my goal yeah it's probably too late
now you know that's a defeatist thinking
never too late people listen people been
in jail for 30 40 years come out and
they hit it it's never too late only
reason they don't make sure they give up
it's a little bit struggle it'll be a
grind but never give up some people are
so close and they so closely it's gotta
cross the street but they give up before
they get a chance to cross the street
they're afraid to get power car after
they've been so far it doesn't matter if
I get about car now I came too far so
[ __ ] it the time of doom everybody
leaves the leader you know I mean but
you got to keep your [ __ ] faith and
don't give up yeah that's right and that
just reiterated their film yeah they do
leave because they had a lead ain't
always on the right side of a pen yeah
sometime you don't know you're needed
but you leave sometime you don't know
hardly but you know it's the right thing
to do you know if I do the other thing
this is wrong I'm laying down from some
bitch-ass [ __ ] mmm that's wrong what's
so right on Mike ever been in jail yeah
so when I was young in the gym I gave
him a trade a well they won't give me
I'm a million gave me millions and
billions for companies in the city but
they won't give me no mother phone give
me a minute a minute of a day mother
yells out 17:8 beautiful just go back
around [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ] your
family come on [ __ ] don't give you the
you you know I think the thing with me
is I don't know what it is about me I'm
just the one that it seemed like
everybody gravitate to know why they
don't they don't lick it none of the the
gang me being affiliated with gangs or
the streets in they overlook all that
they just like Menace you what they call
a rational [ __ ] she could be talk to
somebody so [ __ ] emotional because
emotionally we start looking at this
[ __ ] way and then we start
thinking about slavery something about
my mother knowledge didn't [ __ ] you and
that's just explain you talk to people
yeah but what they and they know I stand
for what I do you smart you read good
for them absolutely man you're killing
it it's awesome to see that against our
laws could you
you ever think so artists can have a
number-one record right and can come
back with the next album and don't have
a big radio here they career fade away
so imagine being band we rely and no
radio not even I can't even talk cuz if
you're a promoter you can't go advertise
so imagine me still being here staying
strong ten years later you know ain't
listen right you're kicking ass right
you standing up but you got always look
at like this you can always be worse
definitely I used to tell people that
they don't understand I'll be like man
it can always be worse but you got to
think about that person who ain't gonna
had a next meal who probably ain't even
got a spot under the bridge they can go
through that they just saw only last on
the last leg always that's why I don't
take much for granted man see but your
your rebel still you know rebels is
gonna always have to fight you know you
only have to fight you know you got it
sometimes gotta rest sometime you gotta
love you have to care the babies you do
some things they're you know the
humanity yeah but you ever get the
feeling if you don't do it if you
you ever get when you love doing it if
you don't do it you just feel bad for me
not being out on front line in the field
all the time oh yeah you could be from
this number
I'm not saying if I take time to go do
me on my own and something happen
I feel hard but if I don't stop what I'm
doing to go jump front line well you
should but how you gonna lead those
people you can't even lead your own
family and I'm [ __ ] with them and
functioning with them and taking care of
them too you know that's part of leader
too they need to be a part of it you
know we're on the front line I need to
be watching them but you gotta be with
Tom and I mean without them there's no
you you can't serve these people without
them
that's your backbone that's all you need
that makes you motivate that makes you
want to get up in the morning I'll be
objective when you know leader you got
to be objective and being objective is
the weird stuff cuz it's almost Carly
like because you have to UM you have to
live your life and you're not involved
with how you live your life it's not
it's not your life and I mean not your
force my shooters not your fault
did you get upset something it's not
your life you're not responsible for
your life but you have to live it so to
speak you can't think about you I can't
make this move I'm doing this I might
get hurt if I do this I might get
arrested it's not your life if you get
arrested not your responsibility
we just have to live your life
na'toth are afraid to live because we
have laws and rules that people created
there's no right there's no wrong people
made that up
who said it's right if you attacked me
who said as long as you attack me
somebody made up a law say I don't like
that as long as you do that him be for
me like you did that made up a law I
didn't like that lama in position make
that a law do that you'll get punished
it's my media to a friend of your son
family member I didn't like that so if
you do it again you're [ __ ] so there's
no writing there's no wrong we made laws
like yeah it's gonna be over quick you
know I remember being nine timing being
champ
I throw the laughs it's over quick what
the [ __ ] happened and then you get 52
and you start saying [ __ ] it's almost
over I got the Pepsi card or soon what
do I do it start living different I
start eating different and I see God I
gotta be at my best
maybe not now but that comes to your
mind
yeah I got a look I got a little while
god I say the same yeah so time I didn't
you know and I feel like another thing
with him as far as him was speaking to
God he's got his hand over me because
even with that like even when I got shot
I got shot directly on my back behind my
heart but I don't know if you seen he's
you did see it's a video of me pulling
the bullet out by myself but the what
I'm saying is just you know it I've been
in so many situations and I always come
out of it why did you get shot
I believe that wasn't meant for me when
I actually got shot yeah but when I got
shot you know three people got killed
another one had got paralyzed
you just put straight pool bullet for
him as long and it's so crazy when I got
shot they take me to the hospital it's
like down there 200 [ __ ] outside the
hospital spook they don't know if they
don't hurt me but the people in x-ray
they're there for me they end up
shutting the hospital down and sent me
on my way I went home and hear myself
are you doing to my shootin you see them
and so possibility he's gonna get killed
what do you do what do you say what do
you think that [ __ ] that [ __ ] gotta get
done uh obviously I couldn't really say
on this podcast but this was gotcha PA
look look this ID no God got me look at
that bullet Mike it's naughty it's miss
teal holds and then break yeah all right
I'll hold of the [ __ ] though
that's Holloway took the [ __ ] bullet
out terminator terminator do some [ __ ]
like this shut up you uh Nikko cuz he's
like man just let me record it for what
because you know yeah it's like they
they push yourself out you know saying
like they move ya automated is gonna
find his way to the surface uh-huh he
like man let me just just let me record
it he record this [ __ ] man I should
that's what I learned with Viral wolf
but it's hot huh pull it was hot what
you mean well you're hot inside of you I
couldn't even I honestly couldn't
remember the feeling of it it was lodged
in my rotator cuff so it just it was
just always throbbing you know saying
like when certain weather when it's cold
[ __ ] my picture with that 4/9 that 45
the other thing was either 4504 them how
do you take that now 45 here you come
like um 90 degree you get better 45 they
push you back mmm and it's so crazy well
that when I got hit I remember I ended
up stumbling over but I got up and made
it to a car and kept him moving man whoo
man thank God yeah definitely thing oh
my god what do you think about God tell
me yeah I've met I believe he's the most
important key to my life and I must say
and something that I've learned my whole
life I've been lured to the street
and [ __ ] in the streets so the way I
look at it is if I can risk all that
every day for four people I say I love
in the streets and in the human form
why can't be his Lord to him so every
everything I do is revolving around him
like I'm just a lawyer person PSO saying
well I'm Lord everybody else I'm gonna
be just the Lord help and I don't always
get the outcome I want I pray every
night at midnight no matter what I could
begin ready to go on stage my fans know
me enough to where they like this is
time he do his midnight prayers and um
when I do it a lot of stuff I pray for
to always come though the way I want it
sometimes people may doubt it I'll be
praying like please let them live but at
the end of the day my Lords he still
remains well I mean cuz I feel like he
got me through a lot of stuff man when
when it seemed like hitting rock bottom
with nobody though how do you perceive
cardiopathy look at God as he is he from
- what the white man create Carter do
you think art is your own in the video
source honestly I couldn't say so how
you got here how you got here who are
you where you gonna live here I think
about a lot of stuff as far as when I
leave here what it's gonna be like but
you kind of hit that date and road at
some point where you just you know
really no it's just I think I'm at a
point where you think like we just died
like you know we no longer will this
like boom we're dead and the energy that
you and I expressing right now they
right now you know what you're gonna say
right now before you even say that you
think through that die that energy right
now you ready to answer me with that you
know what you're gonna say and we can't
hear you think that I you know I'm
talking about yeah I honestly think this
is me I think if we actually left
physical form I honestly I don't see it
being over I don't but I mean yes can't
write that maybe denial yeah then later
but
and every time I look at dead plants of
this flower nothing is it over for this
is it's just a shell where's the essence
of the flower died where did it go did
he just go blanket blacked out or is it
just hovering over the essence is so
powerful this is just black out no long
exist
how's that work yeah you know we are
never know cuz we know but then you know
what don't what CI and I believe when
people say they actually talk to people
in spirits or like I just don't play
with that type stuff I stay far away
from it but if they are able to talk to
people in that way then it's definitely
something after death and in that aspect
if it's truth interesting well even the
physical form doesn't just go flip get
blipped out of existence
you know our physical form if left hole
will decay and rot and go to feed the
soil and plants and the earth it'll go
back into the source even our physical
form so our spiritual form is definitely
swirling around in the ether somewhere
maybe that's why we we always swap it
and fix and fly than Anthony [ __ ] could
we know they're gonna eat it at the end
and the life to go devour
you know what I was younger they used to
say well we doubt us will we come back
well that's funny um we heard that too
on some of these seance you come back to
the tree a bug ant rock imagine being a
[ __ ] rock might be cool might be so
much stimulation so much [ __ ] oh just
get baked by the Sun yeah if if it's
true I hope I'll come back as I'm strong
yeah that's the whole thing right we
live in our egos we have no control we
can imagine thinking about living with
no control maddening everything you
think it means nothing you have to wait
for it to happen
that's the course you have to feel
helpless
worship that's only realized only reason
we're gonna worship it let's be happy at
the end of the [ __ ] boat we're going
to prison and even when we get
imprisoned we may not even praise much
but the fact that we're going we're
gonna pray a million times within that
time we get to put in the duration it
takes to get the prison before we get
there there'll be a million prayers to
God what was the main thought Mike when
you we use coming home you just thinking
more I'm gonna I'm gonna change there
you've been I'm finna prove up what was
wrong up and get my second chance after
you went to jail like what is your
thought process coming out like revenge
yeah yeah I'm stupid I stayed that place
for three years getting prepared for
revenge not thinking about love anything
who are you gonna get revenge against
Mike anyway that laughed at me I'm a
[ __ ] clown
everybody laughed at me and said things
about me a [ __ ] had some negative to
say about me else somebody Nelson
somebody put their two sister or
somebody said son against me and some
face has certain for me I didn't like
the way they said it for me yes
everybody [ __ ] you everybody all had to
boil in my head I couldn't wait to get
out I was a flash my money my belt my
car my house my plane oh my god yeah
very for it wasn't my fault everybody
else's fault yeah anybody else is what
I'm in here you know even I had nothing
to do with it and nothing to do it they
both [ __ ] them [ __ ] they
hated me all along they're all jealous
of me [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] them who came
to visit you good friends everybody
everybody yeah I mean I had more I had
somebody visiting I couldn't have time
to do my job and stuff had to listen
come at this time where I could look at
there are too many visitors and so many
visitors and some of the days coming is
just too many was it surprising who came
to visit you or did you or mostly I knew
I was a good [ __ ] when I was on the
street I was a little good I'm always
gentleman so
people came everybody who Melissa
Michael Jackson mother his father came
when he came Bobby came what LL Cool J
came was ice cubed his name Tupac came
who else came [ __ ] hell okay that's a
bunch of [ __ ] a lot of people
came would you talk about huh what would
you guys talk about first of all they
better have the money for that [ __ ]
machine I've been leaving for the visit
so I let the mono have bring money with
you make sure you have money for the
machine so if you don't got no money I'm
getting about I can't stand there
[ __ ] for two or three hours and then
even though [ __ ] from the machine some
forget some snacks yeah that machine
yeah because that's you know I got a
brother don't - like senses I go there I
gotta add a roll of quarters of XY
that's next money yep and I used to get
up oh listen so I'm in prison right and
people are saying bring me less I'm
gonna make a hundred pieces of letters
day right they don't like what happened
to me so I'm in there where the God has
been in prison for 30 years right so he
said Mike he's reading these letters
they say Mike you don't know how to read
they I'm not reading it what's [ __ ] me
or not I read so not allowed mean that
you can read um knowing basic reading
but I'm saying you don't know how to
read the letters what people are saying
with you know you know you saying umm
the cryptic message so to speak I don't
understand what they tell me they said
the cryptic message and he said Mike
listen if there's anything I could do
for you please let me know think you're
in jail like he need money so he was
explaining he said eh Mike tell every
one of these people to send you $100 a
week or even a month and so I did it
because he wrote the list cuz I wouldn't
let a much of a pen and paper guy so he
wrote the letters for me and he said the
MIT want to say anything and then when
the first time delivery came and around
30 or 40 people sent came in with a
hundred bucks I got scared oh [ __ ]
they're gonna catch it we're gonna get
locked up they'll give me more time I
got paid I panicked I panicked a it's
panic that Saturday's
I was lying to these people I need him
when I have [ __ ] 990,000
my book is my friend you hit that dog
[ __ ] here did that dog [ __ ] tell him to
send you $100 and I fell these people
sent me money and I hate free class in
Maryland go to jail because I'm I had
just what the jail could I gave him a
letter and he told the girl he with me
and the girl was sending him jury and
money and stuff he told us then they
told me might go visit the girl the
girls here she wants to meet you go down
there huh she gave volunteering he
thought she thought that he was me
so ventually she told the people that I
took all her money and stuff so he
brought me laughter wasn't me and
eventually they found him because he had
the jury and stuff and they shipped him
up and he had to get up out of there
you're gonna get another charge pro90
thought it's it's you could do and I
hate the holiday oh you'd be surprised
what if you every break it down the
serum or no that's what you do you got
90 thousand your book you're imprinting
you're doing time alright how many cars
are they there you send money to their
house boom boom boom boom if they rap oh
you have it so way yeah I'm [ __ ] I'm
doing everything here the guard yeah I'm
living like a king
Trane love everybody you need betrayal
of man that's love too because they get
on your backs are you just checking them
let another you're doing wrong [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] with me
that's two that's love to you guys you
can't say his bad side you don't have
nothing bad you have to look at no none
of this is bad all this is done in good
perspective don't look at it cuz that's
go put them let's go to put a negative
mark on your psychology this is that
[ __ ] mean this is bad to think that
this is love [ __ ] don't do this [ __ ] no
more good you got to come out of your
character someone it sounds bad but
you're doing bad in the name of good
it's not bad you know like so fire do
know but it's not in that bad
you kissed the right people with the
right people man yeah it's definitely a
place I learned you know the people
moving they never rule before so they
think that's bad or she said that though
no they got a [ __ ] check here though
yeah get on top you're [ __ ]
game of a [ __ ] hey [ __ ] chill out yeah
you gotta be so true that's what part of
making an army about once you hear that
command you and you know the command you
know no hesitation you have to do the
command it's not like you're [ __ ]
dictator none but everybody have the job
what are you here for everybody have a
job maybe I have to think what is he
here for thee yeah I take some commands
saying well then I gotta take command
never too old to learn
I listen I've thrown at this let's go
with the toad now I thought I knew
everything I had every kind of bigger
head and kind of card laughter had I've
been all over the world listen I took
this [ __ ] I know ancient medicine
ancient drug I took the toy I realize I
never did [ __ ] ain't nothing with
nothing to [ __ ] and number the ego your
throat with a bad [ __ ] sometimes
somebody think your ego you feel like a
[ __ ] you see like a [ __ ] man [ __ ]
you you [ __ ] gonna die got nothing
when I came out from under that shelf
what the [ __ ] with that I want to do it
again I want to do it a [ __ ] it took
all you take all the way pay for all
that [ __ ] ego you thinking you're a
bad magic man you're gonna young life
all your life you know you baby I'm beat
a bunch of shots to be a dish it and all
son you're nothing your ego is going
scared you don't even know what you're
scared you're gonna see anything you're
scared that's thinking you should going
scared it's scared you know we need our
ego we have our Eagle comes for defense
mechanism put us down ego say now you
ain't no [ __ ] man are you showing you
know I mean it tells you that it
protects you so much but then it gets a
little carried away sometime like people
always say get rid of the ego I think
the ego is good you just got to be on
you gotta be worked with I guess anybody
all right all said ego is bad equals
it's not the baddest it's made out to be
I don't believe that I agree
there's a purpose for sure yeah
definitely we wouldn't have it was yeah
and some of us that don't have it people
got to give it to us people gotta teach
us how to have it
yeah cuz you need to have some yeah good
no wait no wait born with it yeah to my
teaches you it I'm going to teach you
you get it from somebody I think you're
right to Mike about the ego because if
you don't have enough ego then you don't
stand up for yourself you want to get a
[ __ ] your life and you're nothing what
do you think you worship you can't be
here for nothing class not gonna put us
here for nothing
even though some people believe they
died for nothing they've done and
they're like you're not here for nothing
okay I won't
I won't accept the fact that people are
useless I used to think that [ __ ] I
wouldn't accept that no other people
uses because I was useless I was one of
those people that throw useless so I
can't I can't think people to use it I
think people are better than me and I
can't think if I think I'm good they
gotta be much better than me it's
awesome great poet brother this is good
stuff we hear where the god is the
sacrificing this [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ]
up let me listen name the game your
money belongs to your children from when
you not hearing them and I'll be giving
it away and all that [ __ ]
these people gotta help you and pay for
this [ __ ] you know I mean yeah worst
come to worst you gonna [ __ ] add you
put down but these guys do for movies
now what they do for movies a grip and
my friend did they write letters out and
they had people donate for them to
finance their movie and they and they do
it they don't even know her they do it
this is a I need this much money to
sponsor my movie I don't know how to do
but they put it out there lease or
something that people sending them money
even know them
they never did a movie before there's
good people out there even though they
make bad mistakes sometime there's good
people I won't believe that people are
bad this is think they should too and
that's what I met as bad people because
I made them bad cuz I thought they were
bad we gonna work on that this month ago
hopefully next time I hit you a mic I
got Bob he's gotta believe in it you
know I mean believe in yourself
and I gotta believe that [ __ ] ain't
believin nobody should be dead she died
of OD I should've died of AIDS I should
have all this [ __ ] that guy ain't give a
[ __ ] I'm still yeah I can't believe I'm
here might as well try to live now I
tried to die their work I'm living let's
see what this [ __ ] takes me to kill
myself again works it's amazing this is
real dude
you want to take yourself brother yeah
we out of here this is another episode
of hot boxing awesome night we had an
awesome gas and I don't have anything
you want to say to these people like it
anywhere get anything no all right cold
up coming on definitely make sure y'all
support whatever y'all see me having
going on and definitely stand up and
support and they've seen his family you
know the minute you know pimp see ya bro
may he rest in peace man real real good
person and I was spoken yeah you know
man is so crazy I got a long list of
father soldiers from from temped in
Houston you know we lost a lot like fat
Pat big Hawk DJ Screw Big Mo three two
grace man my field got a lot of letters
ago you know it's crazy human beings
don't live too long it's like every like
bugs like trees like certain certain
flies at least for only three hours
within three hours you know what it has
to do at the [ __ ] devote this - above
it's hard to have to find somebody that
likes to mate with and then it dies that
when do after that raise the kids and
then I die how fast that it's must be um
the metabolism must be working so fast
three hours you gotta do so much [ __ ] in
three hours
Brielle don't come back being there but
you think that fly might think three
hours is an eternity
well working on high-frequency them
[ __ ] so much thanks Trey okay train
love we got episode alright so I guess
there's mother's nickname for Mike trail
of would you marry Trey no need to find
a good woman inventor you will you know
and that's our art - that's our art -
you know um most people like um I try to
explain to my son have to be like my
father like to be like your father
I [ __ ] for sport you know me but you
but the ticket meant for you to get some
money
he's got to use that dick to get some
money and get some prestige to make you
know me to better your life that's your
dick it for you know I mean that's just
for the breeze to promote the breed
respectfully and profitably but we are
so crazy you wanna stick enactment we
supposed to get money
[Music]